welcome everyone I'm Anne Creek ler I'm
a professor here in the photo science
department at USC and it's my pleasure
today to introduce our author and
speaker Maria our mood Ian I must say
that I am proud as punch to have her
here because she is one of my former
graduate students and many people in
this room can share that honor Richard
was here a minute ago and you can share
it and so we all want to take credit for
you so that's how well we think of you
Maria's right now a lecturer at the
University of Auckland's department of
politics and international relations and
her most recent book even though she's
been out for a very short period of time
is a book on war correspondence and it
grows out of research that she's done
over a number of years because of her
interest in foreign conflicts in various
parts of the world and so she's going to
share with you today her most recent
work interviewing correspondence right
hi thank you so much I'm so happy to be
here and thank you for coming thank you
and twinkler I'm just deeply grateful
for what you've done in Cathy Ballard
and I see some of my favorite people in
the room and that makes me
extraordinarily happy too so
before I start talking about this book
reporting from the danger zone frontline
journalists their jobs and an
increasingly perilous future and I have
to add the typeface is really small so
if you're my age you have to get extra
thick glasses but you know it makes the
page count smaller and so that makes it
easier but the title says a lot it is
about frontline journalists war
correspondents certainly but also people
who report on authoritarian governments
organized crime and what they have to go
through to get the stories why we get
the information we get what are the
considerations that they make in order
to look into these situations and in the
end how they may rest it from censorship
and all of these things that go on in
the struggle the information struggle
which I sometimes call an information
war so let me put it into a little bit
of a context first so this grew out of
both my PhD dissertation and also my
first book the first book was called
kill the messenger the media's role in
the fate of the world and I was
interested in understanding really what
that role of media had been in all kinds
of conflicts and all kinds of situations
around the world
so what I concluded from that there were
11 case studies and the main one that I
usually like to talk about is Rwanda
next to Burundi there they used to be
attached to one another they have
similar dynamic similar ethnic groups
and they both had genocide Aliss Therese
but after the genocide of Rwanda in
which like 800,000 people were brutally
slaughtered a lot of NGOs international
organizations went into Baruti to try to
prevent that from happening
and there and what they did is they set
up media that would act as an as an
ethical screen to change the messages so
instead of having this sort of hate
messages that you probably heard about
in Rwanda which demonized the Tutsi
people actually galvanized people to
help annihilate a group of people in
multiple awful ways but in Burundi what
they did was they changed the whole
equation they humanize the other they
tried to help people understand what the
roots of the conflict were they they
refused to air statements from leaders
that called for more killing so instead
of hanging they old what you what we see
sometimes a he-said she-said being the
most dramatic and awful statements they
said no I'm sorry we're not going to put
that on the radio please come back with
something that is constructive and so
and it did help to change the dynamics
in Burundi not for very long
it worked for a while woundes a little
bit conflicted again first thing they
went after was the media of course to
change those messages but so I was
interested in ethical journalism and I
was interested in what is ethical
journalism what is the impact it makes
why do we get the stories we get and
these were all of the factors that went
into my interviewing about 32
journalists who do this kind of
dangerous work and so let's see where is
the good place to begin here wars have
changed war makers have sort of two
planes in which they fight on right so
there's the real physical battle but
then there's also the frame war or the
information war where they want to
persuade as many people if they can that
their site is right and the other side
is wrong it in its broadening an
audience as much as they can it's
telling their story the way they want to
tell it it's essentially their version
of propaganda Ani
side so Wars have changed in a lot of
ways for one they're not clear-cut we
don't have one state versus another much
anymore we have these messy chaotic
conflicts and that makes it hard for
journalists to maneuver and within these
conflict zones it makes it unclear what
territory they're in and who's
controlling that territory but then
there's also the communication factor
which has also changed war and conflict
and part of that is this thing that was
supposed to democratize the world right
bring about all these wonderful things
called the Internet and the Internet has
done some wonderful things right
it has democratized in a lot of ways
NGOs can now communicate with people all
over the world people who witness things
can be citizen journalists who can
communicate there is an amazing array of
things that the Internet has given to us
but at the same time the Internet has
also become the means for war makers
rebel groups terrorist groups to
communicate and so what happens to
journalists ethical journalists want to
go in there and tell what they see is
the truth something they witnessed a way
that they see the situation accurately
and as an example of something that I
came from the book about what these
journalists do sometimes some of you may
have heard of Marie Colvin she was in
the news recently she was killed a
couple of years ago in Syria but she and
Allen little who was at the BBC where an
Iraq joined the first Gulf War when
there was there were two sides of a
story there had been a bombing and the
Iraqi government said the US forces had
killed civilians the American forces
said no we didn't
and so these two journalists went in and
physically counted bodies and that's
part of what an ethical journalist would
do go in and say look let me set the
record straight you're saying this
you're saying that we're gonna go
physically go there and tell our
audiences what the reality is so with
the internet and with people being able
to use their own frames and their own
propaganda and their own misinformation
what uses a journalist they're kind of
in the way of that story so if me there
were different phases of journalism
there were phases of journalism when
journalists went in with their side of
the conflict and in some cases were
considered an officer of their side of
the conflict there was a phase say in
the 80s where there were a lot of rebel
conflicts going on and journalists were
able to go from one side to the other
side and ask each side for their
particular interpretation of what was
going on why are you fighting what are
your concerns and that was perfectly
okay with everybody
because they needed the journalist to
tell their stories and so they weren't
targets well now they're in the way the
Canal Road you got their own microphone
everybody's got their own media and so
this is why we've been seeing
increasingly a rash of killing in places
such as Syria they don't want this
neutral voice to come out and you know
maybe not so neutral as some of the
things I found in the book there is
quite a bit that's not neutral because
journalists are very much guided by what
makes them human it is their humanity it
is their emotions it is their deepest
cares and concerns is their interest
that drives this story gathering so
without journalists what happens we get
one side or the other or two conflicting
sides we don't know what's true we
know where to put our face and so this
is a troublesome kind of time in terms
of those of us who both want to engage
with our governments in some democratic
fashion want to know what our
governments are doing or others it's not
always governments these days lots of
private contractors lots of privatized
militaries lots of things like that
going on but then there it's also for
the policymakers that don't have
information in many times so one of the
journalists I interviewed a guy named
Roy Guttman was talking about how
journalists missed the story in
Afghanistan and didn't see all the
developments that were going on and
didn't report them and so then all of a
sudden you had this sort of big
problematic area so people couldn't make
decisions without good information so
what's happening today because it is so
dangerous in parts of the world like
Syria it's a lot of news agencies are
refusing to send their journalists in
michaan's France Presse is one that has
said we will not accept freelance
material so if you've gone to Syria and
you've got photos and you've got stories
do not come to us because they want to
discourage people from going in and
risking their lives getting their
throats slit so it creates sort of a
dilemma right so on one hand we want the
information we want to know what's going
on on the other hand if they're not
gonna come out alive and what good is it
and this is something that journalist
said over and over again some of them
still go but it's it's interesting how
they do it so one journalist they
interviewed who remained anonymous
because she does go back to Syria and
does not want her name in a book but she
is Syrian American so she can fly under
the radar as we speak she is covered
anyway because she's of Syrian descent
and Muslim and so she has a fake ID I
don't encourage this for the journalism
students but they
she wasn't the only one that used a fake
ID but she slips in and out of the
checkpoints seamlessly when at one point
she went to Egypt during the uprisings
and she met a Canadian guy on the
airplane and they got to talking and she
said okay she walked you strated the
whole thing you're gonna sit in the
front seat I'll sit in the back seat
they'll ask you questions here is one
place where sexism helped her because
they didn't even bother to ask her
anything they assumed she was his wife
and she got in there and reported some
of the best stories you could get out of
Egypt so these are just some of the ways
that these journalists operate
I will many of them were like we do it
by the rules we get passes we get them
stamped by the appropriate group
whoever's in control of the area we do
it all illegally as much as we can
because that's our ticket out and
Guttman said that he even had his past
stamped once by Isis so but he you know
then pushes the envelope a little bit
more a little bit more and a little bit
more and then he's the guy that
discovered the first the first discovery
of the concentration camps in Bosnia and
wrote about it and this was just by
charm offensive getting in with his
photographer talking up the guards
giving them a little candy you know
giving them some cigarettes cigarettes
apparently go a long way in many parts
of the world and then seeing in the
background what they weren't supposed to
be seeing which is these guys getting
their heads sheared like sheep skinny
obviously hadn't eaten for a very long
time malnourished sick and so that was
how they saw that there was something
going on and he went to refugee camps
and just started asking people asking
people and found other people who had
either escaped or had relatives that had
been taken so here you see the struggle
right the government
to control the information the
journalists are trying to get the
information but within a certain
[Music]
umbrella of rules I see Michael parks
back there who is in the book by the way
and one of the things that Michael parks
said that I thought was so important is
you know the guys with the guns make the
rules do you remember saying that
Michael yeah the guys with the guns make
the rules and so you have to abide by
certain number of rules and he didn't
all the time by the way like in South
Africa he's he sometimes did and
sometimes didn't and sometimes got
caught or so I if I'm remembering the
story right he hasn't read the book so
he might be mad at me at this point so
but that's but that's just part of what
happens is sometimes the rules are a
little bit too unreasonable and the
journalist is trying to get information
out for the audiences the things that
guide these journalists are often a they
want to they want to tell you something
that is important that they think is
important so this the Syrian American
journalist who is one an example that I
think of you know this was a country
that she cares deeply about these are
people she cares deeply about
she has enormous amounts of empathy for
people sympathy for people and she's
truly upset and angry and saddened by
what's happening and would like to see
something happen to take care of the
situation and almost invariably most of
the journalists I talked to this was on
their mind like this is awful stuff and
we want the world to act most of them
were very disappointed why isn't anybody
doing anything Guttman was the exception
really and the rest of them had sort of
resigned themselves to we are setting
the story straight even if nobody does
anything at least there is a record and
that in and of itself is a public
service and remember Alan little saying
it in a democracy having the information
is always better than not having the
information and from my first book I
argue having accurate information can
mean life or death so the other aspect
of this is that local journalists and
foreign correspondents have two
different sets of complications and
about half of the interviewees were
local correspondents who live in the
regions where the problems are and I was
struck by an enormous amount of courage
first of all in both parts to do this
kind of work the local journalists these
are their friends their families their
communities that are getting completely
blown apart in many cases so Kamal Chris
pH who was the editor of Oslo Virginia
which is the daily newspaper in Bosnia
he put that newspaper out every single
day throughout that Bosnian war if
people needed to know what happened to
their loved ones where do we get water
what's close the international community
gonna do anything and he lost I can
count 5 right now of his own journalists
somebody machine-gun sprayed his office
he happened to not be there so he risked
his life over and over again he sent his
family away finally and continued to
work unable to communicate with them
because who had a phone but he felt like
he had to this was their duty this sense
of duty was so important to get this
information out another local journalist
that I was really struck by is a
gentleman in pakistan named umar Chima
who discovered through his own
informational finding documents some
public documents putting them together
that something like half of the
parliament had never paid their taxes
it's a different kind of a story than a
foreign correspondent would cover right
it's something that matters to their
local community and it's something
that's kind of out
rageous and so then he started to write
about the intelligence service in
Pakistan and how they were behaving
improperly at best and he got kidnapped
and he got tortured for at least a half
hour of torture and humiliated and
shaved and photographs taken and then
dropped off two hours an hour outside of
Islamabad where he lived and had to put
herself back together again you would
think that would be discouraging right
the guy kept doing the work and his
family were like can you please stop
doing this journalism thing now you know
we're a little bit concerned you know
that this is it's just going to get us
all into some trouble and but he said
that there were several things that he
did because he felt committed to his
country he was offered jobs in the
United States he was offered jobs in
Britain but he said you know this is my
country and I would like to improve it
so first of all in Pakistan it's a
little bit of a stigma to have gone
through something like that it's not
like in the United States where you can
go find your shrink so he was dealing
with himself his friends were avoiding
him and he said what he learned to do
was to focus on the present
so every time a fear would come up or
the horror from the experience he would
focus on the present and then he did a
few other things and this is important
for the journalism students he practiced
being so extraordinarily professional
and generous with all of his all of the
people that he was reporting on and all
of the agencies that he reported on such
that they liked him they didn't come
after him again so he said you don't
have you cannot misquote people you
don't have that luxury it's a luxury to
misquote people it is not appropriate to
be
mean or rude you tell the facts you put
it in context you don't accuse people
you don't blame people but you give them
a bigger context you make it a policy
issue a governance issue and if somebody
says I don't to give you a quote give
him time give him two months if you need
it and so he's managed to keep reporting
on Pakistan still how am i doing on time
okay very good
some of the journalists were so
discouraged that they wanted to leave
journalism and or just report on
something else for a while
they had seen too much they were just
gutted emotionally and gutted by the
lack of international community's
response so some of them actually that
was part of the harm that was done is
that we lost really good journalists
through this trauma that they've endured
and so the different kinds of trauma of
course four of them had all been had
been kidnapped in my interviewees but
even of the ones that were kidnapped the
things that were the most traumatizing
to them were not necessarily those
things that happened to them there was
things like seeing people's lives
shattered telling the story to me of
this elderly couple living in a corner
of a shelled out hotel having lost
everything not being able to contact
their family and asking the journalist
was a BBC journalist would you he was
going to Croatia said will you please if
you go to Croatia look up my daughters
and tell them we're okay and so the
journalist did that he took the note to
the daughters and the note said please
know that mommy and daddy are okay
everything's gonna be fine
and we're going to be sipping tea
together very soon and that was so
gutting to the journalist because he
knew they weren't gonna make it so here
they had written this very generous note
it gets me to and he delivered it to the
daughters knowing that three in all
reality it's very unlikely that they
were ever gonna see their kids again and
one of the things he pointed out by the
guys that he's wearing a tie and he said
this was one of the things that was
inspiring was the guy refused to let
them take his dignity they had taken
everything else but he wore that tie and
so these were just remarkable stories
and remarkable lives that I heard from
these people who I think are also
remarkable people why do we get the
stories we get it's a lot of things one
it's access access is key and
journalists are always negotiating this
so they ask for permission sometimes
they get it sometimes they don't if they
don't get it sometimes they try to go in
anyway many of the journalists I
interviewed had snuck into their regions
some of them used gifts we call them
gifts I have a funny gift story another
journalist he won't let me review who
who she is but she was always accustomed
to packing things like alcohol
pornography cash into her luggage and
then at customs they take them out that
was part of the entrance fees she said
this time they took the things out and
then they picked up her hair rollers and
the guy said what's this
and she said you know hair rollers
because all my life my wife will like
this
hair rollers became the entrance fee and
so this is the first step in determining
what it is why we get the impression yes
sometimes you can't even get in to see
anything there's huge vast arrays of
places they're never gonna get to so the
second thing is journalists own
interests matter so much and earlier
when I said you know this sense of
empathy so there's a sense of empathy
there's also a sense of outrage
they are generally covering these things
that are outrageous that they are really
angry about this should not be so while
we talk about objectivity and journalism
there's this aspect that is not it is
humanity that sort of Michael parks used
it is their humanity there's guiding
them it is their emotions and their
humanity some of them did not intend to
be covering things like human rights
they went in because they were
interested in history unfolding before
them these big stories and wow we're
here and we get to see it but then they
witnessed other things and Carol
Williams was one of these who she was
she was covering the Bosnian conflict
and met this young boy who had seen his
teacher blown up in front of him
and this changed her perspective and he
was getting to hear all of the you know
the more militant people talking about
shooting up the other side and and she
said you know what we're gonna stay here
as long as we can we're gonna get the
story because she was just like this is
not okay these are young boys you know
getting completely traumatized at a
young age and propagandized at a young
age
we're not leaving so this happened over
and over again to where they start out
with one thing and they get drawn in
because of these very human kinds of
stories let me think
there's anything else I really I don't
want to talk too long but
I want to take some time for questions
so I just you don't know what I was
going to do so we talked about access we
talked about interests but then there's
there are always these other aspects
that are things like punishment and
censorship in some places you have to go
through military censors and those
military censors you're supposed to run
your story through them in order to get
it out the other side and they may ask
you to take something out or put
something back in and most journalists
would comply with that one of my
journalists didn't and one of the places
that they had to go through a censor was
in Israel and he said well you know what
I'm from New Zealand I'm pretty far
below the radar so I just went with it
they didn't notice so it's so much
dependent on things like that like where
were you reporting from who are you
reporting for if you weren't at a very
big publication or a big TV station you
might be able to get through below the
radar and so there was this sort of
struggle on that and to then there's
punishment and they were very cognizant
of being careful enough that they didn't
get kicked out of the country but could
push the boundaries just enough that
they could still get the material out to
their audiences and then of course
there's a big safety issue every time
they had to make a decision about a
story they were doing am I gonna get out
alive and in one piece and if I'm going
to take that risk is it worth it is
there something that I really think is
important enough for me to risk my life
and limb and some opted yeses as I
mentioned at the beginning some still go
so what do I open it up for questions
thank you for sitting and listening and
see what you guys want to know
[Applause]
maybe I have any questions both
journalists who were foreign
correspondents and also local
correspondents
did you see that their emotions got in
the way in different ways yes I would
say not in the way I would say the
emotions acted more as a propellant than
a repellant so Northern Ireland is a
great example in Northern Ireland they
had like two and a half decades of
conflict and as one of the journalists
said we had had it up to the back teeth
with he-said she-said and you know death
and destruction
so once the peace process began in
earnest that's what they focused on and
they focused on it largely out of this
discussed about the conflict and also
this deep desire and sympathy for
victims they were tired of reporting on
victims they wanted an end to the
conflict that was one example I would
say that the other big example I talked
about just a little bit is you know when
this is your own family and friends and
community that is getting ripped apart
it's a much more intense commitment that
comes in this reporting what's happening
and the information that you pursue is
different it's like so kamal bosnian
journalist i thought when he said look
you know yes we care about these big
human rights stories that are gonna
shock the world but we care about these
little stories too that means something
for people who don't have water and who
were wondering when the aid is coming
and who don't know where their kids are
and so it drive different kinds of
stories they drive a different kind of
intensity
and the focus is different so in like in
Northern Ireland it was yes we are good
we're gonna frame this conflict a little
bit differently and it wasn't like like
they said this is inaccurate there's
still accurate it's just a different
frame we're gonna focus on the
peacemaking doesn't mean that you don't
cover the conflict you might cover it in
the context of a peace process you might
ask different questions you might
instead of asking who's to blame for
example you might ask how is the
progress going with the peace process
there what is a potential solution for
this conflict so it's kind of a
different set of questions going on all
driven by I would say journalists own
their emotions and their cognitions and
their beliefs yeah thank you for that
question
yes sir do you know how many carries
special contingency insurance
how many carry special contingency
insurance I know that the ones that work
for the big newspapers and they tend to
have the insurance and it comes into
play sometimes but I know the
freelancers don't always have that and
that's a problem because they're facing
all kinds of risks too but sometimes the
insurance dictates certain things as
well flak jackets some people don't want
to wear a flak jacket because it makes
them a target I'd several journalists
say I don't want security apparatus
around me I don't want a flak jacket I
don't want anybody to know him a
journalist I want to blend in that is my
safety but other journalists went in
with armored vehicles and they had the
vests in the back of the car and they
went they had two cars everywhere they
went in case one of them broke down it's
a whole different set so I don't know if
I could give you the percent or the
numbers but it's just part of that is
just individual preferences for how much
security they want
and how much the insurance was demanding
and in some cases they've just refused
to follow in that case yes so how do the
journalists or is were there different
ways by which the journalist decided
what not to report this is something you
mentioned when you talk about Burundi
right so part of what we would probably
have considered good and humane
journalism is not responding to the to
the loudest and most extreme voice right
and at the same time I think that would
be a difficult thing for journalists to
do is to withhold information because
probably the very ethic of the
profession is that you know if if it
happens that people should know about it
so today do they do they feel conflict
do you think and do they resolve in
different ways yeah just cut whatever I
so this is kind of a framing question
really right so when when we're framing
a story all of us because we're all
framing all the time
it's what you focus on and how you
contextualize it as well so if somebody
is a calls for like in Burundi calling
to slaughter the other side that's
probably not the most responsible thing
to put out there do you even want to
report that he said she said it's a good
question would it make more sense to
them instead report on the next answer
to the question which might be you know
why are we in this conflict in the first
place like and keep going deeper and
deeper into this what this is oftentimes
you end up getting to the question of
power right power struggles resource
struggles that sort of a thing so it's
like you may have a big transcript and
an article is really small and so what
you put in and what you take out is
really discretion and telling the story
that you want to tell I would say it's
more how they contextualize it so I
didn't get a sense to anybody withheld
information of something significant if
they saw it witnessed it
but it would be more of how they framed
it with in what context yeah
the net of journalists that is created
in such zones if we talk about local
journalists you probably have local
jostle each side each of the side so do
they share stories I don't know make
friendships beyond and how how it really
works and how it affect their work so
maybe make sure I understand your
question so you're talking about how
journalists from various sides of a
conflict either sides or foreigners and
local journalist how they work so that's
that's really interesting too so let's
start with that
foreign correspondents local corresponds
because that's a really interesting
thing
often times the local correspondents
become part of a foreign correspondents
entourage where they are working
together on some of these stories there
was also a time and I think it still
goes on where foreign correspondents all
go together and sometimes even report
together on these issues and so
especially if they're from two different
countries or three different countries
they are not in really in competition
and so they end up becoming you know
friends and the friendship becomes a
source of information so some people
said well you know journalists all hang
around together because they all have
good stories to tell and they're always
telling good stories there is sometimes
a concern that it can become insular
right sometimes we can get always the
same story over and over again
but but they do rely on each other and
you ask the question might insurance
earlier right and so this kind of goes
together to Terry McCarthy who is one of
my interviewees longtime foreign
correspondent for mostly the big
American TV stations and magazines he
said when he started he would just buddy
along with somebody from another big
publication and they helped him learn
the ropes he said today the insurance
companies are not letting that happen so
much
so if somebody doesn't have coverage
insurance coverage they might say I'm
really sorry my insurance company won't
let you come along so that is kind of a
new development as well but yeah the
camaraderie is that I think a really
important part of journalism Thanks
a Rob I raised this when we spoke before
so maybe to be good to do it here as
well with more time to reflect and it
was the the case and Michael parks will
remember this - it was an event here at
USC about two years ago in the heat of
the Ukrainian conflict and a couple of
young reporters a team sort of
capitalized for me this dilemma between
their similitude on the scene humanity
emotion and traditional journalistic
standards and this was the case where
these were the best of the modern these
were people who had quick studies with
digital technology not trained in a
journalism school
had not come up through a traditional
organization but happened to have local
contacts language skills they were there
and they were intensely reporting with
images and interviews great stuff but at
the same time as they acknowledged in
this panel
they were censoring themselves because
they had decided that there's one guilty
party in this conflict and and there's
the good guys and bad guys and we are
going to report so that people
understand what we understand so we're
not going to show when the good guys
happen to do bad things - we're gonna
slant from the very front lines how do a
deters or anybody deal with that because
what an asset to have people who can go
there with these contact skills and
immediately give great material but who
might not have signed a pledge or been
through a class in ethics or have any
training in journalism as well so and
it's a problem now when people can't get
into certain areas because they vilify
one side if they can't get the other
side story right if you can't fully
understand the conflict from different
sides then you do end up not
understanding a big part of it
yeah so the especially and also with the
budget cuts that are going on the
inability to send journalists out as
much as they used to one of the
journalists talked about how she wanted
to go back to that conflict in Ukraine
she had covered it for years she they
wouldn't send her and so they wanted her
to report piecing it together from
information she was getting essentially
from Ukrainian news outlets right and so
that is one of these problems we are
this is this is definitely becoming
something that it's harder and harder to
check right I don't if you don't have
people on the ground and obviously
journalists can't cover everything if
you don't have somebody who is trained
in that look we really do want to be
neutral so even though we have our
emotions and it's our humanity that
guides us as journalists there's this
fairness of being able to ask each
person from each side of the conflict
you know because people generally don't
think they're gonna be fighting because
they're bad guys like if I'm fighting I
don't think I'm the bad guy so it's just
this is becoming a bigger problem
because of lack of resources - it's a
big problem also because of social media
and citizen journalism that are not
trained that are putting things up
without really fully giving it the
context that it needs I hope I answered
your question
yeah yes and yes you first division the
journalists are being discouraged to
like put themselves in danger and to be
a foreign correspondent is that more of
like a passive discouragement like don't
go to this area or an active
discouragement like you want me to pay
cut both we're not just not like you get
a pay cut but we're not going there
we're not going there there is a lot of
that going on now and there are a few
exceptions people who can safely
navigate but they're increasingly if you
go into certain regions parts of Syria
is the best example you're really taking
your life into your own hands and even
so even the umar who my pakistani
interviewee said there are certain parts
of pakistan i will not go into because
if I go in there I'm not coming out and
you're not getting a story either so not
only am i gone and dad but you're not
gonna get no audience is gonna get the
benefit of knowing anything more because
I'm gone so in increasing this is
getting recognized and some are saying
well maybe we should train citizen
journalists but then are they risking
their lives too it's just a very dire
time in terms of what it is that we need
to know and how are we going to know
this material yeah what are some of the
challenges that like freelance
journalists face versus journal and
stahma relations yeah so it's much much
harder for freelancers journalistic
organizations are now doing quite a bit
of hostility training and there are some
companies that actually train journalist
what to do in a hostile situation for
example and if you get kidnapped what do
you do and so there are companies that
actually trained journalists to do this
freelancers it's expensive the other
thing is in you know insurance is one
thing if you do want any kind of
apparatus if you do go and you come back
highest and most of them did most of
them are very affected by the work
they've done big companies they will
usually help pay for you to go get some
counseling and whatever else that is
that you need you're a freelancer you're
on your own
another thing is you work for a big
company you can get you do get suppose
you get imprisoned and a country that
you snuck into well the company's gonna
work really hard to get you out if
you're on your own it's much harder your
parents are gonna be calling your
friends so you don't have the same kind
of leverage that a that a staff
journalist has and the same kind of
ability to communicate with you know the
government officials and that sort of a
thing too yeah so if you can go with a
go be the company anything else yes do
you think freelance journalists are more
can decide more what they choose to
report as opposed to a journalists who
work in the big companies I think it's I
think it's a mix because even
journalists at big companies have to
make a pitch to their editors and they
have to persuade their editors about the
news worthiness of the story
Danny gold who is at vice news until
today he just tweeted out that he's on
the market so if anybody knows a good
job for Danny gold but he wanted to
cover Burma and he was looking for an
angle because nobody was really he
couldn't sell the idea of going in and
covering Burma and so he framed it as
Asia's apartheid and so that made it
more interesting and then he connected
it to Hillary Clinton because she had
gone there and you know so there are
ways in which so and he was you know on
staff but he still had to persuade his
editors that this was a worthy story and
it was what he was interested in
so and the more you're interested in it
the more you're able to persuade it but
you might have to find several angles
ROI Guttman Pulitzer Prize winning
journalists been doing this from the
time he was a wee boy and now he's in
his 70s and still at it he's a
freelancer now but when I talked to him
he was I think bureau chief in Turkey
for McClatchy he expressed enormous
frustration with his editors from time
to time when he knows he's got this
story and they won't let him go with it
so I yeah I think it goes both ways at
least with if you're a freelancer the
only extra thing that you have is if
your main editor says sorry now we don't
want that you can go to other places but
again you know you deal with a lot more
risk in doing that yes the gentleman in
the back Pakistan next to Pakistan in
between India's Kashmir and it's
actually a place I want to go to but
wondering I've been hearing more about
it lately there's some conflict there
and I don't hear much about it I don't
know if it's being covered or how it's
being covered on if you can address that
yeah and I don't know that I can tell
you specifically about how certain
regions are being covered now I can tell
you that are you interested in going
yeah so there are a few ways to go about
this there's something on Facebook
called vulture Club are you aware of it
find baltra Club vulture Club is a place
where foreign correspondents go it's one
of the places and they talk with each
other and find local journalists and
local translators that can help them
navigate a foreign territory and these
these they call them fixers it's not a
very nice word but these fixers are
generally the people who are from local
communities who can tell you where you
can go where you can't go sometimes
they'll get you in trouble so you have
to be careful I had one journalist who's
fixer got him kidnapped and he had to
jump out of a moving vehicle to escape
so you've still got to be careful but
you can find your you can at least find
somebody who knows cashmere and who
knows how to get in where you can go
where you can't go but just double-check
everything and can translate for you I
can tell you about the culture can help
you understand the context keep in mind
again these are local people so they
have a perspective so that's where I can
tell you about cashmere really more how
to go into cashmere yeah
one other thing that I didn't talk about
two other things that I just want to
mention one is that social media has
become both good and bad so journalists
who cover Mexico for example in the drug
war they found that friends and friends
of friends were actually working for the
drug lords and were following them on
Facebook and so their lives were kind of
at risk because of this and it wasn't
any fault of their own
it's just that in certain parts of the
world you have to align with one or the
other to survive and so Facebook and
these social networks became a dangerous
place it became place where whatever you
say gets translated into potential
danger for you as well the other thing
is that with social media and citizen
journalism there's a lot of information
now that is getting put out there by
people who are not necessarily trained
they don't have the norms of neutrality
and of accuracy there are organizations
coming up now that are fact-checking
some of this stuff one is called story
ful and so these videos that get posted
on YouTube you can sort of see if they
check out through these outfits that
spend all their time seeing if these
videos are really authentic are they
always right on probably not you know
but this is the world we live in now yes
in the situation in Armenia presently
that there are the social movements that
are going on the movement for more human
rights and more freedom and these things
can you speak a little about the
situation in the coverage also of
Armenia and their present-day
politics I should have known you were
gonna ask that question and I should
have prepared better I can't say very
much about what's going on right now
other than that I know that there is a
very vibrant civil society and
journalistic society that are working
extremely hard to try to really start to
protect the environment in human rights
and other types of civil rights that
have been oppressed in Armenia for quite
some time and that the government is not
particularly friendly to these people
though I have heard recently that the
citizens of Armenia can be pretty strong
and are standing up to law enforcement
officers more than we can do here
standing up to government officials and
arguing with them you know so I have
great hope I just don't know how long
it'll take anybody else yeah I thank you
[Applause]